I have a few methods that can help
people yeah and I'm going to create a
service called uh kick them out nice
good branding kick them out and what are
some of the services you offer yeah what
else what do you do one would be walk
into the house with the flamethrower
[Music]
so we've kind of talked about this
before on this channel but now it's
really really moving forward Ford
just filed uh a patent for self-driving
cars that repossess themselves oh
that's he possessed themselves what the
[__] does that mean if you don't pay the
bill it drives back to the factory dude
it steals it steals itself is that what
that means yeah fall behind on your
payments and your car could simply drive
itself away that's [__] tight that's
kind of tight whoa that's the best dope
ass feature and what's and what's
interesting about that from like a uh a
kind of altercation standpoint is you
don't even run into like the repo people
yeah does it work does it work the other
way like if someone tries to steal your
car it just drives back home
that would be sick as [__] that better
be a feature because that'd be dope if
it was just like it just goes to the
right spot they're not gonna make it
work in favor of the buyer
but then what if you just put the car on
bricks and take the wheels off oh yeah
they just start spinning really
convenient that's all kind of crazy
though like a car could just be on the
road there's no human beings inside
that's pretty crazy yeah how's that even
gonna pass is that even legal but what
if you just forgot you didn't set it up
for automatic payments and then you
forgot that week to pay it and you're
just driving and then you have an
emergency and you're like oh [__] my
wife's giving birth when you're going to
the hospital and you go you haven't pay
your bill and then it's [__] driving
you back you're like no a hospital
here's the thing though uh while even
though it's not approved yet obviously
because the original Pat was filed like
in 2021 but a more recent patent was
just filed like two weeks ago called
systems and methods to repossess a
vehicle
um but they're the way that they
Envision it is that it's capable of
disabling different functions in your
vehicle dispense as increasing tiers of
forewarning punishment so fresh you
can't roll down the windows yeah then
you can't turn on the AC just by here
they're slowly shutting down everything
so first it could uh like take away
exactly like you said your power windows
and lock you out of parts of your
infotainment system if that doesn't like
work or get your attention or have you
pay bills or something like that you'll
lose like AC it's like getting grounded
and [__] yeah automatic uh lock and
unlock features and stuff like that so
like it can basically control almost
every feature remotely is this even
Ford's demographic though I feel like
this would happen in Nissan there's a
BMW demo there yeah bm3 Series BMW I was
thinking Nissan Altima and like Dodge
Chargers challenges and Chargers get
repoed a lot I think those guys need but
then Challengers depend if you're
military or not and a lot of times those
guys aren't good with money I already
like this part the stereotyping the car
user isn't that isn't a thing that they
hide cars on base so they don't get
repoed all because they can't go yeah
yeah I've heard about that wow so the
guys use the cars only on base going in
circles they can't leave the base they
just like park it on base so that the
the repo guy can't get it but the moment
you leave and go to that 7-Eleven across
the street the repo guys are just like
I'ma take that charger back damn yeah
that's the thing man but that puts all
the repo places out of a job if all the
cars become this right yeah all those
Armenians have to find other jobs I mean
that that would definitely take the Repo
Man out I mean it sounds like it's gonna
move towards that anyway I mean repo
guys are are tow truck guys anyway so
it's kind of the same yeah I mean and we
already know about the assembly line
workers that are being replaced by
machines every day anyway you know what
I'm saying have you ever seen a real
repo go down like on video or anything
no but I watched that fake ass TV I like
that one because it go down like that
did you guys ever watch the Karate one
where they had to repo a car from a
karate studio and then all of these
[__] karate students came out and
they started having a major Rumble oh
that [__] doesn't make sense to me I
still can't understand the logic of like
you didn't pay for your car so someone's
there to take it and you're mad about it
I don't understand I understand well
what I realized is a lot of people they
they get older but they're still
children you know what I mean yeah like
a lot of like like a lot of people like
kids like they don't have logic right
they're like hey if you do this you're
not gonna get candy they'll do that
anyways they're like oh you chose not to
get candy
still want the candy and I'm like oh
[__] that a lot of adults are like that
like like you didn't pay so you don't
have your car I'd probably get mad [__]
you know because it's not like mad at
the logic it's like mad at the situation
yeah like that you know what I mean like
I have emotional anger regardless I'm
just not gonna blame myself right now
uh because I was getting my car towed a
ton when my when I was working on my old
[__] and I would always have to get it
moved and uh I would meet a lot of tow
truck dudes and some of them used to be
repo guys I was talking to this one dude
he had a big ass scar on his head and I
was like damn how'd you get that and
he's like I used to be a repo guy and a
dude shot me Point blanket oh my God
what the [__] just because so he just
moved over to Towing instead of repo huh
well most tow guys are repo guys that's
what I'm saying he didn't really move
that far over yeah you could just do
both but like he's like I don't do repo
anymore because of that like every time
you have to fight with the guy if he
sees you do it I mean that's the same
thing if you ever Miss like a phone
payment or uh like Cable payment like
your cable just shut off or your phone
will just shut off yeah but nobody has
to show up and take away like this I
know they don't come sniff your I think
the best way the best example for me
would be squatting so like if you stop
paying rent technically that space is
owned by the person that's renting it to
you and then a lease or a car payment is
the same thing it's not yours right so
you're if you if you miss your payments
and all that then what ends up happening
is you get evicted but I guess uh if
it's not a lease and you're buying the
car it might be the same way as buying a
home and you're missing those mortgage
payments then what happens is the bank
or whoever owns your loan can kick you
out
depending on how many payments you miss
so then the car getting took taken back
it's not really stolen it's more like
you're not taking care of what you
borrowed yeah and you're not a you know
we agreed to this but you're not [__]
doing it so now it's mine yeah because
it's technically not yours yet until you
pay the loan yeah but it's crazy that
some people go over their head and they
and they buying something that nice like
a lot of stuff that gets repoed is just
way too nice but you could have just got
a cheap ass car but you can't Flex on
the homies like that can't Flex on a
normal car I hate to be a repo guy man
that's just crazy
damn did you know that in order he was
telling me too that in order to find
these cars they have these like uh
snitch cars that have cameras on them
you ever heard of that so it'll be like
a regular Prius and on the top if you
ever see like a circular uh it looks
kind of like a Roomba and it's on the
top of the car that thing's a 360 camera
and what it does is scanning all the
license plates oh my buddy has that on
his cop car because all he does is drive
around the neighborhood it's constantly
looking for warrants yeah and for that's
tied to uh license plates yeah these
guys have people like that too but all
it can do is tell you if someone's
defaulted so it'll just scan plates and
then if if it beeps out then it
automatically sends a signal to the repo
guy like oh that BMW 2015 whatever is
right here and they just that's how they
can find it all the time because you're
like how the [__] do they know where you
are
crazy that's banana but what if someone
steals a repo card and you steal the car
from a stolen burglar or stolen burger
just stole it from a thief and then they
call it and they're like my car got
stolen and then the repo guys actually I
stole it from the guy that stole it from
you
that's a special episode then I don't
know
this is uh they they even say like you
know it's like the question is would
Ford actually intend on following
through with the patent it's like you
never know but you know a lot of these
companies and stuff they'll still file
these types of patents in order to uh
possibly the potential of monetizable
Concepts in the future you know yeah or
even owning it so that the competition
can't own it exactly yeah oh that's true
because it's not especially back when
you were saying like it doesn't even
seem like Ford would have that type of
demographic that you know what I mean
but it's like some of these companies
might just like file it just so it gets
bought out by or they can buy it and
then now lease or license that patent
too Nissan Altima exactly the Nissan
Altima specifically
Ultima it'll beat him to the punch dang
yeah cause I don't think Ford has a
problem with like their customers
missing payments most things though um
no because with Ford you know I think
they're gonna get recalled and the whole
line has to get fixed before that even
happened before that yeah the default
damn oh you know what happened to like a
mutual friend of ours that she uh she
had her apartment on Airbnb while she
was like living out of the country on a
job and then uh she had a guest stay
there and I guess I checked in checked
out in like less than a week and then uh
months months later she had a friend
asking if they could stay at her place
and she was like yeah go ahead here's
where the key is go on in and the dude
was still there no way months and months
later and he had been squatting in the
place since his checkout so she had no
customers in between dang yeah I don't
know what happened
ladies I don't know what the deal is but
she maybe she ended her like thing her
availability and that dude was still
there
there's a guy at the house I guess you
couldn't get him out
because he wouldn't leave yeah so what
do you what can you do have that I'm
gonna make us I'm gonna make a
windshield somewhere squatting in your
house it's probably the most like the
worst nightmare especially in California
yeah California he said it Anthony not
me Shut the [__] up I have a few methods
that can help people yeah and I'm gonna
create a service called uh kick them out
nice good branding kick them out and
what what are some of the services you
offer yeah what else what do you do one
would be walk into the house with the
flamethrower and be like high fumigation
team and then just start burning
everything in your own house yeah we'll
see one too and then like he's like it's
all fine I'm like you bet
[Laughter]
.com what if he just goes upstairs
the fire goes up and it burns the house
he will die if that doesn't work then
guess what water time and then we get a
water we doze it down
the flood you know what what can you
legally do to a swatter so uh
catch them doing drugs you got to catch
them doing something illegal some
cocaine yeah you'll plant heroin
everywhere no they were they were like
oh if you see them doing drugs and just
call us and that's the only time they
can because the bigger crime though it's
a bigger crime yeah it's a it's a
different crime the the first things I'm
going to prove in crime that's the
problem wait it's not a clock yeah
Welcome to California doing heroin no
that is oh but but just just over
staying at someone it's that's the thing
is it's it's not a it's not a proven
crime you have to like take isn't that
trespassing
but you have to prove it so yeah it
depends on it goes state by state that's
the thing it's yeah let's go stay back
because like let's say like uh like the
story I told them is across the street
from my place there was a girl that was
living there for months squatting in a
house and they were like well who's to
say that she didn't get permission from
someone like well we know she didn't and
they're like how do you know and then
when the owner found out uh they were
like who's to say that you didn't say it
was okay and now you regret it like
there's all this stuff they have to work
out factually was that the cops yeah
it's like it's a whole thing it's not
helping well the cops can't do it the
court has to do it the city has to like
find uh find that party guilty of it
after deliberation of all these things
otherwise you could just you could be
living with someone and then go oh
they're squatting and they'll just kick
them out like I can't call my kick them
out service yeah flamethrowers Anonymous
I just [__] bust the door down don't
be like ah this guy fire fire and then
they go next door I don't know what to
do if someone's squatting in your own
house though I don't know what like how
you can violence you know what you're on
drugs are but you can't you can't commit
a bigger crime to get them out of your
house roles you're gonna get in trouble
yeah more than they are like no because
by that time they're afraid of you fear
does a lot of things like make them
never come back
telling me no turn off the [__]
cameras you're telling me if I came in
there and chopped
[Music]
thank you